[Music]
Michael I've known you since you were a
child you have a gift
you always have if there's an answer to
my disease you'll find it
I should have died years ago
why am I still here if not to fix this I
have a rare blood disease and I'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly label
I want to see you get hurt more than you
already have this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
I went from time
of increased strength is speed the
ability is echolocation
and then overpowering earth to consume
blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing the
old good guy hang up what's up ty can I
help you
y-yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime and what terrible crime
is that this one nah [ __ ] I told this
all wrong quick history lesson this all
started when the Joker and I broke up
it was completely usual and soon enough
I was back on my feet ready to embrace
the fierce goddess within it's oh so now
that I cut ties with mr. J I'm about to
learn that a lot of people want me dead
oh hello I'm at the top of that list is
this guy
but it turns out I wasn't the only
daemon got them looking for emancipation
betrayed him utilities BSS what you are
so cool you're dumb enough to be
building a case against him so unless we
all wanna side very unpleasant death
we're gonna have to work together
sure
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah are we ready
oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bottle I
named him Bruce after that hunky Wayne
guy my life doesn't be what you probably
think it has we all have our struggles
have you ever been left a long long time
ago you so many times yeah all the time
[Music]
welcome to the future
life is good but it can be better
why shouldn't it be all you need to what
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can save today
I take I want in return
everyone must see
[Applause]
and we'll need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
Oh art ah that's just this trashcan it's
just a trash camp
yeah yeah I just have nothing
[Music]
come on I got this job this family
but nothing lasts forever heard you had
to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do I've lived a
lot of lives but I'm done running from
my past
and now you're out there I know you know
I'm out here so we gonna talk like
grown-ups is that what we are
it's good to see - yes what brings you
home
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure
it's gonna be a hell of a reunion
stupid family back together again you
got fat
[Music]
and initiate sequencing memories are
made of this what is this place
I'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed at rst we'd
rebuild the most important assets in the
US military soldiers like yourself
you're the first who we successfully
managed to bring back but improved
enhanced with the technology in veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger you will heal
you instantly porridge
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going I got unfinished
business
oh that's not good all right sundown
and initiate sequence okay who is the
next target for elimination
these are made of live tell me do you
remember anything do I know you guys I
don't think so
they've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
you can't control me
sure about that
is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
and here I could just write this is a
famous MVP
what's the last thing you remember Danny
he said we had to run the reason you
survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know how mutants are would anyone
like to shared their first time brain I
was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control
Sam I've started panicking
people got hurt Roberto my girlfriend
and partner Giuliana
I killed 18 men one by on
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out here caller
so we can help you get better
I suppose something I don't think she
wanted me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your greatest fear and
later live through it until it kills you
he's there we can get out of this
together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]